le taux d'inflation au Canada atteint
son plus haut niveau depuis plus de 32
ans en effet en juillet dernier les prix
à la consommation ont été de 13%
supérieur à ceux de juillet 1980 les
années 80 un taux d'inflation aussi
élevé laisse prévoir le pire pour les
consommateurs les temps sont durs
prenez le chauffage le gaz pour les
autos manger surtout là
aujourd'hui le plus grand chose 50
pièces
augmentent leur prix comme jamais et le
coût de l'énergie fait mal un avenir qui
paraît sombre les gens se laissent même
aller aux pires prévisions si tu les
riches qui veulent avoir notre peau ou
quoi on sait pas ce qu'on va pour le gaz
qui balader ou 5 ans on montait ça le
double ou le triple ce que vous pensez
de vos enfants par exemple devront se
priver de choses dont vous avez usé en
abondance j'ai bien peur que oui et pour
juguler l'inflation et bien les taux
d'intérêt montent en flèche la Banque du
Canada doit fixé son taux d'escompte il
est passé de 14 à 14,19 % une nouvelle
augmentation du taux d'escompte il passe
de 14,19 à
14,79 % des taux hypothécaires
à du jamais vu de plus en plus cher
d'acheter une maison de la refinancer ou
de la louer à cause des taux d'intérêt
faramineux sur les hypothèques on
assiste alors à des fermetures
d'entreprises à des mises à pied
massives et un taux de chômage inégalé
au Québec de
15,8%. 1980 sera une année de récession
pour 6 des 10 provinces canadiennes le
Québec échappera tout juste à cette
tendance mais dans les mois qui suivent
le Québec sera aussi en récession pour
des observateurs de l'époque la hausse
des taux d'intérêt sera malheureusement
la recette parfaite pour une récession
l'accroissement des taux d'intérêt
augmentent et contribue à l'inflation
l'économiste Pierre Fortin en 1980
allaient dans le même sens par exemple
du gouvernement fédéral qui avec ses
politiques anti-inflationnistes et taux
d'intérêt élevé ces budgets restrictifs
créer du chômage or on sait que c'est
les jeunes qui écopent le plus de
chômage quand ils montent cette époque
le taux de chômage chez les jeunes était
de
17%. Pierre Fortin avec le recul
constate que nous en sommes pas là
actuellement mais il y a un parallèle
selon lui une différence entre
aujourd'hui puis à l'époque c'est non
seulement aujourd'hui le taux de chômage
de départ est beaucoup plus bas qu'à
l'époque mais également le taux
d'intérêt est beaucoup plus bas lui
aussi nouvelle récession en 1990 mais
beaucoup moins sévère que celle du début
des années 80 avec un taux directeur
beaucoup moins élevé le pays dit
Statistique Canada est déjà récession
preuve les 150000 emplois manufacturiers
perdus j'ai bon espoir que ça va sur
place bientôt
je confiance en l'économie oh je suis
pas inquiète parce que en général au
printemps ça redescend alors j'attends
le printemps Pierre Fortin estime que
les prochains mois seront décisifs qui
est déterminant ça va être de savoir si
la Banque du Canada va continuer à
augmenter de façon importante les taux
d'intérêt être capable de décoder si le
ralentissement va continuer de faire
baisser l'inflation comme on veut c'est
ce que souhaite sans doute les
consommateurs qui ne veulent pas revivre
la période économique difficile du début
des années 80 ici Jacques bissonner
Radio-Canada Montréal